[Music]
we were called in about five days back
when the first body started appearing
since then we've been burying people
nearly daily most come with their hands
tied behind
their backs some had gunshots wounds in
the head
others in the back we buried more than
40 so far
we were told by refugees that people
were being killed and thrown in the
river
then we found the bodies hands tied
behind their back some shot in the chest
some in the head we knew there were two
grains from humera
[Music]
there are several burial sites like this
one along the city river each with
different numbers of bodies
but people here in wadalhu say not all
those found in the river were pulled out
and while the bodies of those who died
trying to escape tigre are buried here
there are reports of similar graves in
the region where the death toll is
[Music]
unknown
[Music]
oh
[Music]
the needs that have been spoken about in
tigre
are indeed what they have been
advertised as
they are huge they are urgent they are
important
and now the needs are growing